This
modern world of science and invent lives of particular interest to women
for the lives of women who have been manifested by a big new horizon than
those of any other group.
Confound them swearing as have been accomplishments in the remeasure field as your
research is in the home happy applications of scientific
achievement gap perhaps the most far
reaching and it is through training conditions there. I remember
have become the greatest beneficiaries in the modern schools.
So I don't have released them. From months of the year you grab you can messes with
the process of living.
Cameron The things we using and crude methods of manufacturing the sensitive.
I things of the past for an increasing McGarvie. Today
life mean and power may be obtained by pushing
buttons and Kremen manufactured an appealing product of all
the world are available at the house by the or.
Indeed the arm back down he need not go back to the miracles of
modern communication and camp potations.
Now Norman has applied science degree to
play in the home but I have provided I'm dreaming that of economic
opportunities for women today many of these are them are granting them
living under conditions made possible on your way
basically all of them that the system commonly known scientific
development is most
startling by mere facts of this new and growing economic in the pan
and upon women
themselves from the history of our times is written it must
carry card as to bring freedom African physical back East
and South Australian women have undergone. Their music citing
the cave.
Remember the. I was going through a magical evolution of the last half century to
be largely credited to the
current in the laboratory and were translated in the practical
use of crude because that's
Labor premiers on them and that a mechanized world would not be a
playable run and put to them quite the contrary should be true.
I mean can read to our minds which have accomplished so much in
the realms of a plaid
pants will unite with the same rule you have them to control
their creation. Again. So I'll still miss you
leave research regarding technological unemployment. Is as bison today.
As by either resign or production of labor saving and
comfort living
devices on the marvels of the modern invents and back with which
I am more convinced than is of course there can be place and.
Yes perhaps the most dramatic recent scientific
assignment in the brain here. Iran has
seen an inventors dream materialize by the Wright brothers at Kitty
Hawk become an enemy back to our
They perhaps I'm probably doing but to me it seems that neither
side of modern progress can try to maintain Bremen
as your little map in the O.T. coupled with utility as
does
aviation where any sap and Sandusky embraces many of
those companies and then yesterday them fantastic
impassibility the pilot when that way about two hundred miles an
hour passed by radio telephone to ground space and onto
other planes in the air. M.K. where you have guided by ready all
being received it carries parts of
conditions ahead. Specialist and then new methods of
media logical calculations.
Behind engines reliability and quit measured by hired freaks of
the past is all but I'm believe the bull. I myself
don't know I was smarter but your carried me over the nicest man part of
the processing to him from Mexico City and the many times across this
continent aviation
the modern Xi'an exemplifies the possible
relationship of women.
The creations of science. Farmer women and yet have not taken full
advantage over to some benefit of all is available to
them as to
men as so often happens in them to do seeing the moon or
taking the old public acceptance to pass on to you and only a part
of women family
attitude in aviation they are because of whether or not
their families. Self
live under such conditions
no I am Lastly there is a place with
them in true self for women who work five
grams numbered a family marm our facilities for
employment in the ranks of the leisure time but place and
medium Man I hope this movement will throughout all balances
of Applied Science and Industry. And that women may come with
men the Dr doing their own can appreciate the rock ward. Wrong.
Who have helped
create.